c'est vrai une clémence passent plus de
temps dans ses champs que dans les
musées mais une porte s'est ouverte et
elle a poussé avec d'autres agriculteurs
séverine clémence a passé un après-midi
du mois de mars à dire ce qu'elle voyait
ce qu'elle ressentait devant des
projections de tableaux représentant des
paysans j'ai eu vraiment des émotions
vraiment vraiment forte en regardant
certains tableaux c'est c'est une
sensation que j'avais jeunes jamais vu
en regardant tam en quoi est ce que
j'avais vraiment regarder un tableau
trois mois plus tard la voici avec noël
barbe l'ethnologue du pôle courber
devant le tableau qu'il a tant ému une
bergère
ce qui me frappe c'est vraiment le le
fait qu'elle est triste qu'elle est
comprendrait qu'on l'a on pour la
déposer la c7 bergère et à mon avis elle
est pas sa place elle n'est pas à sa
place elle n'a pas envie d'être là
c'est mon ressenti ces petits moutons
ils sont derrière elle on a l'impression
qu'ils cherchent un peu de qui cherchent
de la tension mais mais elle les regarde
pas je vois pas la relation entre entre
elles et les animaux mais c'est quand
même essentiel dans notre métier sur les
80 oeuvres présentées cet été au musée
courbet quatre ont été commentés par les
agriculteurs une analyse fine qui
enrichit la visite c'est une façon de
voir la peinture autrement c'est de voir
effectivement dans la peinture peut
percuter des vies commandes et l'egypte
est entrée au tableau et permet de le
lire autrement
sentiment d'impuissance face à l'
incendie à la campagne et dans la même
salle l'impressionnant van gogh là les
agriculteurs ont vu la tranquillité
après la récolte toutes ces fenêtres
vers le monde rural du xviie siècle elle
questionne déjà des problématiques qui
ont encore cours aujourd'hui et le
regard urbain sur le monde rural sur la
place du paysan de la société de sa
fonction
productiviste la question écologique
aussi surgi à ce moment là donc n'a
vraiment qui nous permet vraiment de
nous questionner de de questionner aussi
l'évolution de ce monde rural les
paysans chez millet et courbet sont
réellement marqué par le labeur jules
breton lui préfère montrer une image
idyllique de la femme au travail dans
les champs rien à voir avec la petite
bergère
ça m'a tout de suite fait penser à la
condition féminine
[Musique]
dans l'agriculture aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous on a choisi moi j'ai
choisi mon métier moi c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment ce que je veux faire et
cette petite bergère j'avais vraiment
l'impression qu'elle était là parce
qu'il fallait qu'ils soient là et elle a
pas le choix
plus que jamais la portée de la re30 où
son sens au musée courbet d'ornans un
musée ancré dans son territoire